I can actually then hand over to you uh
Minister how we store the the formal
invitation on behalf of all allies for
the Republic of Finland to exceed to the
north atlante treaty so please thank you
and then at the same time I'd also
invite you to the posted your documents
of accession to the U.S government here
represented by secretary Lincoln
thank you Mr Secretary General thank you
secretary Lincoln
now when I've got this invitation it's
my great pleasure to deposit with the
secretary of state of the United States
of America finland's instrument of
accession to North Atlantic City please
secretary blinker thank you very much
well with receipt of this instrument of
recession we can now declare that
Finland is the 31st member of the North
Atlantic Treaty
thank you
and since we are now a member of NATO we
have a very important task and the task
is actually to give to you for the
deposit also our ratification for
Swedish membership this is our first act
as a member state
please thank you Frank I'm delighted to
be delighted to receive this on behalf
of Finland thank you thank you thank you
thank you
and then we welcome Finland to the
alliance and uh we also appreciate that
you have uh agreed also to invite Sweden
so uh this ends this uh moment and then
we will continue outside the building uh
in just a moment so thank you so much
thank you thank you